all right so this is vault of bones I
love this episode this was like for lack
of a better word this is one the more
adorable episodes I've seen in a while
and there's a lot of adorable episodes
this was like really insanely funny
creative and cute it was like really
really cute it's a Finn and Flame
Princess are hanging it out you still
see her father comes in with Ricky Lee
and she's on a she is evil and stuff so
Finn suggests they go into a dungeon
it'll just make her feel better they go
through the forest trying to find the
entrance under rocks and trees it's
obviously very zelda and they find one
and the whole thing is pretty much I get
Zelda out of it I mean I don't know if
they're referencing anything else in
there
but okay you being sarcastic or is there
really something else is referencing
long I mean have you ever played an RPG
besides Elda because Elda's not very RPG
II well okay I mean but like in terms of
like the original original like go get
the key go back entrance in the forest
under a rock you know or a tree at the
pole ever another more for me for me I
took it as just the daily the old Final
Fantasy actually any Final Fantasy the
Dragon Warrior series like any of those
where it's the grinding because when you
grind you go from one A to point B point
A to point C point A to point D like
you're consistently doing this whole
body back yeah going back and forth or
even it could be a knock it like
Resident Evil there's in the earlier
Resident Evil's you had to go through
like part of the mansion then you had to
double all the way back and then you had
to go back yeah I guess Zelda's much
more was a little bit more tight I guess
in that sense where it's like hey you
get you found this now go run this
mission to go back here and do this but
Sally get to do that eight times actly
yeah okay so fair enough um but they go
through this dungeon and a Jim Crow yeah
dungeon crawl and they pretty much
defense are showing her sort the proper
etiquette per se of how
do this good she just wants to set
everything on fire and to do the splits
uh and she's trying to get a little
bored by it and he says okay let's try
doing things your way
she start setting everything on fire
doing a lot of cool moves and fing gets
captured and thinks that she's gonna use
nothing but her flames to get him out of
it and she does it's gonna kill him so
she starts rushing towards him and says
don't go split it even gets the sword
out and says do the splits and this
giant monster Stephen just crawls over
splits edit it was so good it was
exactly what to see in that moment I'm
like I so hope he just tries to do this
that is so great just seeing this big
picture I mean he falls over and pushes
himself yeah come on out and they find
they have like a nice compromise and
she's you know not so evil I want to
trying all the keys and you know there's
still a little hints of like you know I
love destroying you know things and
frizzies concerned she's like you know
evil things and so I like that and then
they open up the chest there's what
looks like a green light or a green
heart and it just wings I have no idea
what that is
um do we find out what that is or did we
just leave that okay so okay there's a
lot of things I like first of all I love
the fact that and to me this very much
shows that you know cuz like is she evil
is she and starts off with that and it
closes with that and it comes back and
me it's very well paced that way and to
me it shows very much that like you can
have it's like everybody's gonna have
you know a bad tendency or invite you
know or anger or violence on whatever
and no I'm completely the nicest person
a person ever
unless you're old or an adorable
elephant or a kid
but what I really like is that they go
and they show that as long as you have
an outlet for a healthy outlet like it's
okay I like her see I like destroying
things that he looks kind of worried and
she's like you know bad things you know
and a lot of people would say okay it's
not the healthiest but it's still better
than the alternative in this world it's
like you know sort of the best thing to
do oh yeah getting that stuff out you
know and it's I really like that I think
that's a nice way especially someone who
does come from an extremely evil
background you know and so on that's
coming in constantly trying to make her
even a parent that's trying to make her
evil and you literally whisper and try
to make her do bad things so I like that
I what I like too is that it really got
both sides of sort of the whole RPG
thing because like as a kid you know I
like to Zelda I liked Metroid don't even
know if you necessarily call those like
diehard RPGs probably not you know but
metroid is a good example though because
they get out with Metroid where they're
the energy containers hidden throughout
you weren't able to get to them so you
get the high jump or two you get the
fruit of the yes beam you had to jump
and kind of go here and then come back
that's a better example actually then
Zell is yeah I mean so and I was a kid I
love that stuff nowadays I don't have
the patience and they pissed me the hell
off and I get bored by them but that's
not all saying they're bad they're not
bad they're you know they're people you
know they're for people who have this
patience and enjoy putting this time to
this game and stuff it's like more power
to you maybe I'm much more patience than
I do they just drive me insane have you
sunk into BioShock Infinite okay but
that's just going through okay you're
just going through the game play it's
like now you go here no you go here now
you it's very rare that there's like a
side mission even the side mission is
now you go here and now you know here
it's rare they had to go back you know
to drop something off you know he had to
go all the sea and BioShock Infinite
always offered something new you're
gonna go to a new place and now a new
place and that's what I like the idea of
going all the way back or you know your
game is almost finished now you have to
go to every single world to find this
one
little brouhaha we made up and it's like
I just went all those ticket worlds it's
it drives me nuts but like I said it I
get it it requires a great deal of
patience and it's just what I I'm very
impatient when comes to games I'm just
like kill things I'm very bad that way
Oh am I like Finn and he's like Flame
Princess no honestly that's what I was
saying that's all honestly we should
make out you should set me on fire and
access yes
no that's one say I so I can be on fire
oh yeah later and then the right slash
fiction about it and it'll be glorious
Oh what the hell slash fiction was even
though it was before
all you do is type in our names I'm sure
what I was looking at exactly but then I
find out exactly what slash fiction
meant and I was like oh no I get over Oh
shipping I was looking up when the term
shipping actually came into existence
because I never heard the term shipping
until a year or two ago
yeah actually do I have to actually ask
it a condom from a group of people
because they're like you know do you
ship you know these two characters from
Avatar and I'm just like was something
that was going on in the comments
section about shipping in a list up the
bag all the little people oh yes like
kind of a knocking people who ship yeah
I know that stuff and it was like
growing up I never did that I never
looked up to Ninja Turtles and thought
oh my god it totally awesome splinter
and April I hooked up yeah but were they
were good together I never do that much
either I think that's more something it
came a lot not that did exist but
whether it was made popular by the
internet option yeah and that was the
thing I was curious about when because
my daughter started using shipping and I
was like ah that's like what the hell is
shipping mean I don't get this what
they're put on a ship and so not to see
it yeah
but yeah that's how I found out what
slash fiction was it was like the one
that they bring up is Kirk and Spock I
was like what Oh or like anyone in Harry
Potter from other said yeah
so yeah I liked I liked going to the
dungeon I liked I likes even work off
each other I thought was very clever
they he finds the gauntlet in that way
he do like yeah and that way like when
she's gonna do something he can you know
put her hands down and say you know we
can touch her and stuff um so yeah I
really liked and I'm growing more and
more to the idea of them being a couple
which I was never again stood before I
was like okay so just obvious
replacement whatever but it seems like
yeah like they really really work and I
like seam together I like team and
compromise uh yeah I just I think oh so
we're gonna do our um I like the episode
I mean I've always been a fan of Flame
Princess I mean since day one I mean
she's been my favorite um I thought this
gum skulls are the glue skulls were very
interesting especially when she blows
open and there's one like jerking off
the tongue or whatever the other water
like I thought was like playing with the
guitars of my neck just like ah oh it
looked a lot more perverted to me like
one are Jews and another one's mouth and
the ones go like this although I thought
well I was like playing it like a guitar
string or something that could be
possible we'll have to rewatch it but I
think I like a really cure that's like
what like I really miss something a few
jokes like that don't like the cook on
BMO's yeah yeah kiss my cook I'm a huge
fan of RPGs I always have been the
classics from adventure on the Atari
2600 to like even Final Fantasy 13 on
Wild Arms Legend of Dragoon
Xenogears like I've always been a fan of
role-playing games so seeing this when I
hear dungeon crawl I instantly think
grinding I instantly think you know all
this stuff and I love how he just gets
the keys like go back to the beginning
do we have to go back we don't have to
we get to yeah and say to me I'm very
much on her side I'm just like why would
I want to go back like it I keep going
for a while you see II have to find
in order to get bad it's like and likes
it I get it it's just not for me so I
was very much on her side but at the
same time I understand fin side as well
so I thought that was a very good sort
of balance that they did there well I
remember when me and Joey were in our
younger days and we were playing I was
playing Wild Arms and she was watching
me and she said she's gonna try it
herself she started playing and I'm like
no no you gotta go over there then you
get it and it was kind of like Finn and
Flame Princess she was like just let me
play how I want to play and of course
I'm like I don't know what I'm doing
though not realizing okay she wants to
do it her way she needs to learn through
her own mistakes in the way she doesn't
know that so I could definitely relate
with this one plus it's also a badass
when her like hand turns into a blade
and she said yeah yeah when she acts in
the door yeah does that little flavor
yeah it's like okay she's just even
better now yeah this one I think had the
coolest Flame Princess moves in it like
if this was ever I mean I think it is
technically a game but it's like if it
was okay if the vector sound was a game
where you could pick any character it's
like I would always pick her because she
would just have the coolest moves
actually they do have the game um oh
it's like Ice King why did you steal
heart garbage something like that
we need to get it it's a multiplayer
you'll have to come over we can play mad
do we play the burrito game it's a
dungeon game it's a dungeon crawl which
we promised people we would do it that
we never do a very good cuz it was the
Ice King and Marceline episode is just
like yeah we're in no way we're playing
this capable you know talking about this
I was like hoping you know someone would
be like oh they're gonna play it no one
cares no one even made a single solitary
comment towards that game and it's like
aw I failed I thought I saw one or two
people but you know it was mostly Shambu
by oh my god I remember he was coming up
my eyebrows so cool no I liked it I
thought it was fun and yeah and I what I
like too is that it's a relationship
with you know it with a girl that Finn
is with and it's not you know are they
or are they gonna be a couple no they're
a couple you get to see them as a couple
and I so rarely see that and I
like that there's nothing wrong with
just having a couple be a couple and
seeing the differences in conflicts that
here come rid of a sexual tension and
get to an actual couple loved one who's
like she's like I wouldn't burn my
boyfriend and Finn's eyes get big it's
all like yeah I mean it's like so cute
and it's like why I never get these
whole you know okay if you have a story
girl once a while where it's like okay
well a couple falling in love and does
the person like me do just does the
person nod you know it's like okay
that's always gonna be a small part but
then it's like they always stop once
they say okay let's be a couple and they
stop and I'm like why that's the
beginning of the cool stuff you know why
do they stop or why they have the
dumbass love triangles or why do they
always you know once they fall in love
it's like well that's the goal that's
all you want if you wanted just him or
her and that's it there's nothing beyond
that and it's like bullcrap there's a
lot of stuff after that and why do you
think I hate I'm not a fan of Futurama
yeah I like that Futurama episodes but I
hate what they did with Ryan Leela over
and over again ya know with amnesia
because numerous episodes when bender is
able to tell the future they see their
future and how good in bed it's gonna be
but for some reason they don't forget
about it yeah I mean I agree I don't
that stuff and I think it's dim and I
think it's like our people finally
seeing how stupid this is is that why
we're finally getting these you know
good things like this in John Adventure
Time cruise smart they're good they're
making stuff but now remember they did
quite a bit of it early on to well
within the bubble gum you know I mean
granted it was a touch different because
you know she's older and he's younger
but it was still the sexual tension are
they or aren't they and stuff but then
they stopped and they went to they said
okay we're done with this let's get this
to something else and at least that kid
they had that sort of segue over and
it's like sit in the in the Lynch
episode and stuff it's it still makes
things a little uncomfortable to like
you know when he's trying to get
whatever from her and she accidentally
cuts him she's like you know that was an
accident there there's already sort of
that tension there so it's like if that
works okay I'll give that a pass I took
it more as finn's a child he
just learning you know relationships and
all that and people's never had that
feeling towards him he was just always
kind of the hero and all of that stuff
and it was just the correct me if I'm
using the wrong - it was an unrequited
love where Finlux her but he she doesn't
even notice him as that he's just a hero
he's just a good close friend and all
that stuff and she knows the age
difference he's gonna get it exactly so
I think it was never the whole oh
they're gonna get together they're gonna
get ten there was more along the lines
of let's see how we can show him dealing
with something he will never be able to
attain and then when you finally you
know as he's going along
he's learning he's growing he actually
gets to be together with her for an
episode and then she reverts back to her
proper age and she's like that was a
while ago we need to stop this you know
whatever and now he's going with girls
his proper aging you will yeah I think
it was just a learning curve honestly I
don't think it was the whole sexual
tension well kid show well okay not
sexual tension but will they you don't
want to use the term first of all second
you know whether or not they'll be a
couple that that's one game no I know I
know
but yeah so I like him as a couple and I
like that they're addressing it's not
like oh and everything's happy and
there's no problems it's like no it's
like when you get together it's like
that's the beginning of a lot and I
think that I hear when stories just stop
after they get together again
everything's perfectly fine oh yeah
stupid relationship things like oh you
are looking at some other guy weren't
you or you didn't call me at the proper
time yeah I mean a bit stuff that's like
yeah cuz that's that's those are the
real issues in a relationship you know
that's the important stuff you know it's
like there's so many factors that you
know play apart it's and they're
interesting and why not talk about them
you know I like that they're beginning
to talk about me or now granted still at
their age you know they're over 13 you
know but but yeah so I did it I really
like that I think that's cool by the way
I want to make a quick that really I
don't know I denounce Ben shout out
whatever we will be at anime Midwest in
Chicago and you guys should totally show
up and bother us or at least bother me
because
I like talking tunas and all that junk
so my wife will be there and he'll be
signing hate people's t-shirts someone I
guess actually sent an email saying will
you send my IT people TV I'm like
there's a t-shirt awesome
but she likes Marshall Lee so what's
will you do looks like you're playing
with boobs now if you're just looking at
stop that young man